OVER.
AMERICAN PEOPLE CHOSE TRUMP'S
VISION.
TIME TO GET WITH THE PROGRAM.
THAT IS THE ANGLE.
WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH AN
EXCLUSE EV INTERVIEW WITH
SOMEONE -- EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW
WITH SOMEONE WHO KNOWS ABOUT
THE STAFF SHAKEUP IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
HE WAS CHIEF OF STAFF FOR
TRUMP AND BEFORE THAT CHAIRMAN
OF THE REPUBLICAN NATIONAL
COMMITTEE.
AND WE ARE PLEASED TO WELCOME
REINCE PRIEBUS.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, MAN.
HOW ARE YOU?
>> GREAT TO BE HERE.
A LOT TO LEARN IN THAT
OPENING.
>> Laura: C'MON!
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT WHERE
WE ARE RIGHT NOW?
THE REPUBLICANS, WE ARE GOING
TO GET TO WHAT IS HAPPENING ON
TRADE.
THE HOUSE COMMITTEE, THE INTEL
COMMITTEE TODAY ANNOUNCED IT
IS SHUTTING DOWN.
THEY DIDN'T FIND RUSSIAN
COLLUSION AND THE PRESIDENT
HAS BEEN SAYING IN
CONSISTENTLY.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE?
>> SIX OR SEVEN MONTHS AGO
THERE WAS A BUBBLING UP OF A
CALL FOR THE POLITICAL
LEADERS, PARTY LEADERS IN OUR
PARTY OF THE INTEL COMMITTEE
OF THE HOUSE AND THE SENATE
SHOULD SHUT DOWN BECAUSE THE
MUELLER PROBE WOULD BE SO FAR
REACHING THERE WOULD BE NO
NEED FOR THESE COMMITTEES TO
CONTINUE SUBPOENAING PEOPLE
AND INTERVIEWING PEOPLE.
IT WAS THE PRESIDENT THAT SAID
NO.
LET THE COMMITTEES DO THEIR
WORK.
SO BEHIND CLOSED DOORS THE
PRESIDENT IS SAYING NO, LET
THEM KEEP GOING.
I KNOW THAT EVENTUALLY THEY
WILL ISSUE A REPORT AND THE
REPORT WILL SAY THERE WAS NO
COLLUSION.
WE NEVER TALK TO THE RUSSIANS.
WE DIDN'T NEGOTIATE WITH THESE
PEOPLE.
SO THE PRESIDENT WAS CONFIDENT
IT WOULD HAPPEN.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN IT.
I NEVER SPOKE TO RUSSIANS AT
THE R.N.C.
I NEVER HEARD OF OTHER PEOPLE
DOING IT.
I NEVER TALKED TO PEOPLE LIKE
PAPADOPOULOS OR CARTER PAGE.
I'M NOT SURPRISED.
I WANT PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS BEHIND
THE SCENES SAYING LET THE
COMMITTEES DO THEIR WORK.
>> Laura: MAXINE WATERS WAS
ON ANOTHER NETWORK TONIGHT.
THIS IS SO HILARIOUS WE HAVE
TO PLAY IT FOR YOU.
WATCH.
>> WHO WOULD BELIEVE NUNES WAS
WORKING IN A CREDIBLE WAY TO
FIND OUT WHAT TOOK PLACE?
AS A MATTER OF FACT, HE WITH
US SIMPLY A MESSENGER BOY FOR
THE PRESIDENT RUNNING UP IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT TRYING
TO PROVE THAT OBAMA FOR
EXAMPLE HAD WIRETAPPED THE
PRESIDENT.
SO, THEY CAN CONCLUDE WHATEVER
THEY WANT TO.
THEY WEREN'T DOING ANYTHING TO
BEGIN WITH.
IT WAS NOT A CREDIBLE
INVESTIGATION.
>> Laura: THAT IS THE
DEMOCRATS' TAKE.
MESSENGER BOY.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT IS NICE
TO SAY.
>> THAT WILL BE THEIR TAKE
THROUGH THE MIDTERMS AND
THROUGH 2020.
THE PROBLEM IN THE MID-TERMS,
OF COURSE, IS THAT YOU HAVE
MARGINAL RACES THAT ARE IN
PLAY.
SO 80% OF THE DISTRICTS ARE
EITHER 90% REPUBLICANS OR 90%
DEMOCRAT.
THERE ARE NO REAL MARGINAL
RACES ABOUT 22 --
>> Laura: WE WILL GET INTO
THE PENNSYLVANIA RACE IN A
MOMENT.
>> SO THIS RHETORIC WON'T
WORK.
IMPEACHMENT RHETORIC DOESN'T
WORK IN THE MARGINAL RACES.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT WANT TO
SEE WASHINGTON WORK AND THE
POLICY-DRIVEN DEBATES IS WHAT
YOU WILL SEE IN THE MARGINAL
DISTRICTS.
>> Laura: YEAH.
SPEAKING OF, ON THE TRADE
ISSUE.
YOU ARE A FREE TRADER.
I HEAR FREE TRADE.
I'M FOR TRADE.
I WANT TRADE.
>> IT'S GREAT.
$360 BILLION WITH CHINA.
WITH JAPAN THEY HAVE $68.8
BILLION TRADE DEFICIT.
THE SOUTH KOREAN TRADE DEAL.
EACH YEAR THE DEFICITS HAVE
GROWN AND GROWN AND GROWN.
HOW DO YOU GET LEVERAGE?
HE IS GETTING LEVERAGE NOW.
>> YOU DO AS YOU CAN SEE
CAREFULLY WHAT HE IS DOING.
HE PUTS THE CHIPS ON THE
TABLE.
HE PUT THE GAME PLAN ON THE
THEN WHAT HE DOES IS NEGOTIATE
EACH PIECE.
CANADA OFF THE BOARD.
MEXICO OFF THE BOARD.
HAD A PHONE CALL WITH THE
PRIME MINISTER OF AUSTRALIA
OVER THE WEEKEND.
TWEETED OUT THEY ARE OFF THE
BOARD.
EVENTUALLY HE WILL PUT IT ON
THE TABLE TO NEGOTIATE ONE BY
ONE.
>> Laura: WE ARE DOING THIS
NOW.
THIS IS WHAT I'M SAYING.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS
CRITICIZING HIM AND HE GOT TO
E.U. AND JAPAN TO DAYS AGO TO
SAY WE ARE STANDING AGAINST
THE CHINA TRADE ABUSES.
DO YOU THINK THEY WOULD HAVE
DONE THAT?
>> NO.
>> Laura: THEY NEVER WOULD
HAVE DONE THAT UNLESS THEY
LOOK AT THE TRADE TARIFFS.
>> IN DEFENSE OF I LIKE THE
MONOLOGUE.
VERY INTELLIGENT.
IN DEFENSE OF PART OF IT, THE
PRESIDENT CHOOSES ON HIS OWN
TO PUT PEOPLE AROUND HIM THAT
DON'T AGREE WITH EACH OTHER.
MAJOR THINGS.
SO EVEN WHEN I WAS THERE, IT
WASN'T LIKE A COUPLE OF
NARRATIVES INCORRECT ON THE
TARIFF STUFF.
THIS WASN'T SOMETHING THAT THE
PRESIDENT SUDDENLY CAME UP
WITH AND MY GOD, HE WENT OUT
WITH THE TARIFFS OUT OF
NOWHERE.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WAS
DEBATED FROM BEFORE THE
INAUGURATION.
HE WANTED THIS STEEL AND
ALUMINUM TARIFFS SINCE BEFORE
THE INAUGURATION.
WE DEBATED IT WEEK AFTER WEEK
AFTER WEEK.
WE GOT TICKED OFF A FEW TIMES
AT THE STAFF AND SAID WHERE
ARE THE TARIFFS.
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
JUST CAME ABOUT.
HE HAS BEEN DEBATING IT
FOREVER.
THIS IS WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS.
TO PUT GARY COHN AND --
>> Laura: THEY ARE SMART
PEOPLE.
>> AND THEY ALSO DON'T AGREE
WITH HIM.
SOME WHITE HOUSE HAS THE SAME
SPECIES OF PEOPLE.
EVERYONE IS THE SAME.
HE HAS NO PROBLEM PUTTING
NATURAL PREDATORS TOGETHER.
LET THEM BRING THE "A" GAME
AND FIGHT IT OUT.
THEN HE MAKE HIS DECISION.
>> Laura: I RESPECT THAT.
ON THE CORE ISSUES --
>> BUT HE IS ALWAYS GOING --
>> Laura: HE WILL GO WITH
HIS GUT.
TALK ABOUT THE PENNSYLVANIA
DISTRICT.
DISTRICT 18.
THIS IS BEING WATCHED BY
EVERYBODY.
THAT IS A DISTRICT THAT IS
REALLY TIGHT.
IT WILL BE REDRUN IN NOVEMBER
ANYWHERE BUT THIS -- REDRAWN
ANYWAY.
BUT THIS IS A BELLWETHER.
THEY SAY THE PROSECUTOR CONOR
LAMB AHEAD BY A LITTLE.
YOU ARE NOT SO SURE THE
DEMOCRATS CAN PULL IT OUT.
>> I THINK IT WILL BE HARD FOR
THE DEMOCRATS TO PULL THIS
OUT.
I THINK THEY MAY BE OVERHYPING
THIS A LITTLE BIT.
REPUBLICANS ARE PLAYING THIS
PRETTY WELL BY SETTING THE
EXPECTATIONS THAT THEY MAY
LOSE.
THE PRESIDENT WON THIS
DISTRICT BY 20 POINTS.
TODAY HE IS UP BY 12, 15.
A LOSS OF ABOUT EIGHT POINTS
IN THAT PARTICULAR PLACE.
CANDIDATES MATTER.
BUT THIS IS REALLY ABOUT THE
TURN-OUT.
I WOULD EXPLAIN TO PEOPLE IN A
DISTRICT LIKE THIS, IF YOU HAD
A BOWL OF POPCORN AND ONE WAS
REPUBLICAN AND ONE WAS
DEMOCRAT.
THE VOTERS IN THE REPUBLICAN
BOWL, POPCORN UP TOP.
THE DEMOCRAT BOWL POPCORN IS
TWO-THIRD OF THE WAY.
>> Laura: HUNGRY NOW.
MY FAVORITE THING.
>> BUT REPUBLICANS HAVE A FULL
BOWL TO TURN OUT.
IF THEY DO REALLY POOR JOB AND
SAY THEY ONLY TURN OUT
TWO-THIRD AND THE DEMOCRATS DO
A GREAT JOB AND GET EVERY
SINGLE PERSON OUT, THEN THEY
CAN WIN.
>> Laura: I DON'T SEE IT.
>> THE DATA SHOWING IT
TRENDING BACK TO THE
REPUBLICAN IN THE LAST FEW
DAYS.
>> Laura: I DON'T SEE HOW
YOU CAN SEE THE TRUMP SPEECH
IN PENNSYLVANIA AND THINK THAT
IS MOJO.
I DON'T CARE --
>> ONE THING ABOUT THE
REFERENDUM ON TRUMP.
YOU HAVE TO THROW IT OUT.
IF TRUMP IS ON THE BALLOT
TODAY HE WOULD WIN THE
DISTRICT.
SO THE QUESTION IS THE
CANDIDATE CHOSEN BY THE
REPUBLICANS?
>> Laura: NO ONE IS GOING TO
BEAT TRUMP.
C'MON.
>> IS THE TURNOUT IN THE
DISTRICT MAKE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE PARTIES?
>> Laura: I AM FEELING LIKE